Project Bloks is a research project,...
...and our goal is to create an open hardware platform...
...in which developers, makers and designers...
...can create hands-on programming experiences for kids.
As a first step, we've created a system for tangible programming...
...and this system consists of three main components:...
...the brain board, base boards and pucks.
The base board works by placing a puck onto it,...
...and pucks can be programmed with different instructions...
...like turn on or off, move in a direction or increase amount.
The board then simply reads that puck's instruction.
The brain board provides power and connectivity,...
...and when you connect base boards to it, it can read their instructions...
...and send them to connected objects like a toy or a tablet.
The boards can be rearranged in different ways...
...and wrapped in different forms and materials...
...to create all sorts of physical coding experiences.
Like a music maker, where you use physical code to compose music...
...and send it to a wireless speaker.
The ultimate aim of Project Bloks is to give all the work we've done...
...back to the education research and development community for free...
...to accelerate the field of physical programming for kids.